what this case is really about is not
health care it's not Obamacare it's
whether the president the United States
is in fact the president of the United
States and subject to the Constitution
or an autocrat who can impose taxes on
his own hi I'm Nicholas tree with reason
TV today we're talking with Michael can
and he's director of health policy
studies at the Cato Institute he was one
of the architects of the arguments that
won big in one court case about
Obamacare and subsidies and lost in
another case so we're gonna talk to him
about that Michael thanks for talking to
me okay just recently we had a
three-person panel of the DC Circuit
courts say that the IRS or the
government can't disburse healthcare
subsidies for Obamacare through the
federal healthcare exchanges we have set
of Fourth Circuit courts I know that it
can how you know how do you feel about
these outcomes well it's really
interesting you've got one court the DC
Circuit which is really the second
highest court in the land saying that
the president has been issuing illegal
subsidies in 36 states we're talking
about a lot of money tens of billions of
dollars that's 36 states because that's
how many states use the federal did not
establish their own exchange so they
don't have an exchange established by
the state which is what the law requires
for those that's the law specifically
explicitly says the subsidies go through
state-run yeah that's the language in
the statute it is it has to be an
exchange established by the state so the
DC Circuit has ruled is that the
President did not have the authority to
issue those tens of billions of dollars
of subsidies to the five million people
who are receiving them in the 36 states
with federal exchanges those subsidies
are illegal and the penalties that go
along with those subsidies which affect
maybe ten times as many people more than
fifty million are also illegal and you
also had the Fourth Circuit saying no
they weren't they were legal so this is
this is a pretty glaring so this is I
mean just to put a point on the the
amount how important the subsidies are
to the exchanges and to Obama care in
the individual market eighty six percent
of people receive subsidies and the
subsidies on average come to about
seventy five percent of the cost of the
premium so this is not an in too
part of the program that's right what
these subsidies exist to do is to shift
from the premium payer to the tax payer
much or all of the cost of the very
expensive health insurance that
Obamacare requires people to purchase
this is why the president rewrote the
law because if he implemented the law as
written then in two-thirds of the
country people would be facing the full
cost of his health insurance program and
the backlash would convince even members
of the Democratic members of Congress to
reopen the hall so here's a question I
mean the you know what what happens next
the the DC Circuit it was a three-person
panel are they going to have a non-bank
hearing in the Fourth Circuit is was
that a full full panel okay so are they
gonna skip all of this and go directly
to the Supreme Court because that seems
to be where this is headed well no one
knows exactly what is going to happen
except the Obama administration which
loss in the DC Circuit said that it will
ask for on bomp review right the play
methods the whole the whole Court all of
the judges will search yes sir there
will be 13 judges that that then review
that three-judge panel's ruling the in
the Fourth Circuit the plaintiffs could
ask for on bank review or they could ask
the Supreme Court to to review the
ruling because right now we have a
circuit split the Obama administration
is asking for unblocked review in the DC
Circuit because they're hoping that they
will overturn that panel decision and
eliminate this what else what is the
likelihood of that well I don't know
really goes to I don't really know what
most people say is the 13 judges that
would sit in that on that on bonk panel
are comprised of eight Democratic
appointees and five Republican
appointees so everyone assumes that they
will vote the Democratic right and
therefore the the panel will you know be
will will be overturned I'm not so sure
I don't think that it's too simplistic
here let me follow up with a couple
questions I mean cuz this is the you
know kind of the unfolding of the
resistance to Obama care after it lost
in the big individual mandate case and
whatnot what is it you know what what do
you think the Supreme Court would do is
there any reason assuming this goes to
Supreme Court is there any reason
to believe that the same Supreme Court
that rewrote Obamacare in order to make
the individual mandate stand
constitutional muster that it would
actually at this point say you know what
this is the straw that breaks the
camel's back and you know we're actually
going to enforce the law as it was
written well I like to think that the
Supreme Court doesn't say all right
we've cut Obamacare enough slack I like
to think that they look at the legal
issues involved and so on the one hand
you have people saying well John Roberts
didn't want to disrupt Obamacare or
bring the courts legitimacy into
question and so he voted to uphold it so
he's gonna do the same again you have
other people saying well that's giving
him cover to do to vote against
Obamacare he's already done that in
Hobby Lobby but John Roberts also said
in his ruling and if I be V Sebelius
that it is not the job of the court to
save the American people from their own
policy choices and that is actually what
the Obama administration was trying to
do to save the American people from the
structural flaws in Obamacare and so if
you go by that part of John Roberts
ruling then he you might conclude that
he would vote against the government and
to uphold ironically to uphold the act
the way Obamacare actually works did did
the government to the federal government
or the drafters of Obamacare really mean
to exempt federal exchanges from being
able to issue subsidies you know because
one of the arguments is that no this was
a way to incentivize the states in order
to get into the game and create their
own exchanges and it seems like
everybody expected more states to
actually create their own exchanges or
is this just kind of sloppy
craftsmanship this was not a drafting
error okay that your your organ toss
that came out the window everyone from
the plaintiffs to the government to the
the Fourth Circuit that ruled against
for the government the dissent in the in
the DC Circuit they all acknowledge that
this was a that the meaning of the
statute is plain it is clear and then
they diverge from there about the
after they look at the relevant
provisions not but not even the Obama
administration argues that this is a
drafting error and if you look at the
pros what is their argument and it's
just that it shouldn't matter in the end
well their argument is as you mentioned
that Congress intended to offer these
subsidies through federal exchanges the
problem there a couple problems with
that there the statute says exactly the
opposite there's nothing in the statute
that conflicts with the language it
speaks directly to that question there's
no legislative history that says that
Congress intended to do that so what
were what we're talking about here is
people using the term congressional
intent but what they're talking what
they mean is that some members of
Congress would have liked the law to
read another way would have liked the
law to authorize tax credits and federal
exchanges but that's not congressional
intent when you have a bill that says no
tax credits and federal exchanges and
you vote to approve that bill that is
Congress intent one of the arguments is
look we passed the specific law and we
better implement that specific law and
if we don't you know then kind of
madness starts to creep that's what my
co-author and I Jonathan Adler had a
piece in The Wall Street Journal this
morning that argues that what this case
is really about is not health care it's
not Obama care is whether the president
the United States is in fact the
President of the United States and
subject to the Constitution or an
autocrat who can impose taxes on his own
totally talk a little bit about your and
Jonathan Adler who's a law professor at
Case Western you guys are the architect
of this line of argument against
Obamacare how did you come up with it
and you know do you think it is going to
it that it's ultimately going to prevail
well I found out about it in an email
from Jonathan Adler he in in August of
2011 I think it was he just happened to
casually mention that the law only
authorizes subsidies and exchanges
established by the state now he wasn't
the one who discovered that but he
mentioned he'd been talking about it for
a little bit and he mentioned it to me
and I was probably the first person who
recognizes the significance
I had already been encouraging states
not to establish exchanges for various
reasons and this became suddenly became
the most powerful reason for them to do
so so why is it a powerful reason for
them not to because actually I mean that
would mean that the
residents don't get reduced-priced
health insurance what it means is that
the law gave the states the authority to
veto major provisions of its regulatory
scheme the subsidies the employer
mandate and to a large extent the
individual mandate a state that does not
establish an exchange exempt all of its
employers from the employer mandate and
lots of its residents from the
individual mandate and by blocking the
subsidies what you're doing is you're
not increasing the cost of health
insurance at all what you're doing is
revealing to the voters in your state
the full cost of Obamacare and if you
want to repeal Obamacare is a lot of
people who were elected to the state
level in 2010 did and I mean they're
elected because of the backlash against
res law then that's an important step
for you to take in a lot of states took
that step precisely to veto these
provisions what is very quickly what is
your preferred alternative to Obamacare
because you're not a proponent of the
the status quo before Obamacare I mean
that was that was a world in which
government was spending you know
40-something cents of every dollar of
health care and things were not going
particularly well what what's your
preferred alternative to Obamacare as
well as the status quo before that well
the the problem with American health
care is that it already looks so much
like Obamacare Obamacare and all the
other government interventions became
before it or making health care more
expensive and reducing the quality of
care so if we want to make health care
better and more affordable particularly
for the people we should be most
concerned about the poor the sick what
we need to do is we need to be
generating innovations that reduce the
cost of health care not shift it to tax
payers but actually reduce the cost of
and this is an avoid them both in terms
of delivery of health care but also
technology new types of ways and ways of
all these kinds of innovations that have
been suppressed by the by government
licensing of clinicians by the tax
preference for employer sponsored
insurance by Medicare by Medicaid by
certificate of need laws where you have
to get permission from the government to
enter the health care market and now by
Obamacare if you sweep those things away
certainly we're not going to have
a healthcare sector where absolutely
every human need is met but we are going
to do a better job preventing people
from falling through the cracks and we
would do under any other alternative
system because that's what innovation
does it fills in those cracks so that
fewer people fall through and if you it
I've been asked this question a lot
since Halden came out you know what
would you do we've got a paper at the
Cato Institute I released it in 2009
during the Obamacare debate it's still
fresh because you know we still need to
make all these changes it's called yes
mr. president
a free-market can fix health care and if
they go to the Cato website they can
read about all the changes right
we will leave it there thank you Michael
cannon we've been talking with Michael
cannon he's director of Health Policy
Studies at the Cato Institute for Reason
TV I'm Nikolas me